Good evening everyone. I now call to
order this April 8th, 2025 meeting of
Lancaster City Council. A few reminders
at the top of the meeting for everyone
with us tonight. Please take a moment to
silence your devices, phones if you
haven't done so already. This meeting
and its participants are being recorded
and live streamed. Anyone addressing
council during public comment periods
should do so at the microphone here in
front of us to be heard both in the room
and on the live stream. Please begin all
comments with your name and block of
residence for our meeting record. Public
comment is limited to three minutes per
speaker and I will use the light that's
here in front of me to keep time. It
will turn green when a speaker begins.
It will flash yellow when there is one
minute remaining and will flash red when
time has been expended. And I want to
thank all of you in advance for ensuring
that everyone has equal time this
evening. For all of those who are
willing and able, please rise for the
pledge of allegiance.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
republic for which it stands, one nation
under God, indivisible, with liberty and
justice for all.
Mr. Harris, would you please call the
role of members? Yes, Madam President.
Mr. Madden, here. Mr. Royo, here. Mr.
Gleas, here. Miss Craig here, Miss Diaz,
Mr. Hirs here, and President Pek here.
Councelor Diaz is excused this evening.
Next item is the approval of the minutes
of the March 25th, 2025 meeting. Motion
to approve. Second. Second. We have a
motion and a second for our meeting
minutes. Counselors, any comments on
those minutes?
Hearing none. Mr. Harris, Mr. Man, I.
Mr. Mr. Roya. I, Mr. Gleas, I, Mr.
Craig, I, Mr. Hirs. I, President Beay,
I.
Right. Our next item on the agenda this
evening, proclamations, honors, awards,
and resolutions of recognition. We have
one this evening, uh, resolution number
23, 2025. Mr. Harris, if you would. A
resolution of the council of the city of
Lancaster designating April 2025 as
sexual assault awareness month in the
city of Lancaster, Pennsylvania.
Motion to approve. Second. Thank you. We
have a motion and a second. Counselors,
thank you very much for uh allowing me
to introduce this uh resolution again
this year. April is sexual assault
awareness month and it brings awareness
that sexual violence continues to be
widespread and affect all members of our
community. During this month resolution,
I'd like to proudly affirm that the
Lancaster YW.CA CA is still Lancaster
Countyy's designated rape crisis center
and applaud the work that they do in our
community for sexual assault prevention
and counseling all at no cost. Uh they
are hosting numerous events this month
to help raise awareness, support
survivors, and promote prevention
efforts. And I'd like to invite the team
from the YW.CA to the podium this
evening to say a few
words. Good evening and thank you for
being here.
Good evening. Thank you. Uh my name is
Theo. I work at the YW.CA Lancaster
Sexual Assault Prevention Counseling
Center. This is my colleague Maddie
Wrestler who also works at the Sexual
Assault Prevention Counseling Center. Um
I just wanted to take a few moments to
talk about what um we offer as services
um for both the council and for the
public. Um, so like you said, we offer
counseling and therapy services at no
cost um to both victim survivors of
sexual violence as well as their
significant others, which could be
family members, partners, friends,
neighbors, anyone who else is um
impacted by that violence as well. Uh we
have a 24/7 sexual assault hotline that
you can call in any time of the day.
We're on call for you. Um, you can call
in if you need resources, someone to
talk to, or want to get set up for our
services. And that number is
717392-7273. Um, and again, that's 24/7.
We're always here um for you. We have
medical accompaniment. We we accompany
victim survivors of sexual violence to
the hospitals. Um, again, at no cost um
to help them through the process and
offer support. Um, similar similar well,
that's a hard word.
simil nope as well as legal
accompaniment. Um we do offer a legal
accompiment as well um and that's to
court proceedings all throughout the way
even police interviews um for victim
survivors of sexual violence. Again,
that's at no cost. Um we want to be
there with all of the systems that um
victim survivors of sexual violence are
interacting with. So we try to be at
each moment we can. Um we also do a lot
of prevention education for the
community. We go to schools, um
workplaces, churches, community
organizations, anywhere really that we
can talk about prevention around sexual
violence and around consent, boundaries,
handling difficult feelings, healthy
relationships. Um and that's something
if you're interested in as for your
organization, you can always go on our
website and the programs that we offer
are on there as well. Um, am I missing
anything, Maddie? Um, I would just add
that we also have support groups as part
of our set of services the first Monday
of each month. So, actually, it was just
last night, we have an adult survivor
gathering that happens from 6:00 to 7:00
p.m. at the Lime Street location of YWCA
Lancaster. So, it's right around the
corner. Um, and all of those services
that we've listed are also available in
any language. We have interpretation
interpretation services through PEAR,
which is the Pennsylvania Coalition to
Advance Respect. Um, so we're able to
call them or even bring them in in
person, again, at no cost, um, to offer
those services to anyone in any
language. So, we're trying to take down
as many barriers as possible there. But
that's everything. Thank you. Thank you
so much for being here this evening. Uh
counselors, are there any council
comments on this resolution of
recognition?
Comments from the public
hearing none. Mr. Harris, Mr. Matt I.
Mr. Roy I. Mr. Cle. Miss Craig I. Mr.
Harish I. President B I. Thank you. And
uh counselors, we will uh I have a
presentation copy uh to present to our
YWCA staff this evening and uh we can
adjourn to this side of the room to take
a brief photo if everyone would bear
with us while we do that. Um and do you
have someone to take the photo?
Fabulous. Okay, we will be right back.
Thank you.
I want to hand
as long
as
it
right. Our next item on the agenda this
evening is our first public comment
period. This is reserved for residents
who contacted the city clerk prior to
the meeting to request the opportunity
to address council. Um again the cutoff
is 2:00 today uh for these comments. So
these are the folks that com excuse me
these are the folks that requested to
speak before 2:00 today. Duration of
comments is limited to three minutes per
speaker and again please begin with your
name and block of residence uh for our
meeting record. Mr. Harris, our first
speaker this evening. Yes, Madam
President. Our first speaker is Russell
Dery.
Good
evening. If you see the green light,
you're good.
That might not be on. Do you see the
green light there? No, we There we go.
So over the past few meetings, we've
heard feedback from the mayor regarding
her views on I guess the ineffectiveness
of civilian review boards and the
general challenges to reform posed by
the city's agreements with the police or
police unions. Um to the extent that
these views are valid, they clearly
represent a significant roadblock to the
progress that the community is
demanding.
So, after reflecting on this, um, I just
have some questions for the council that
I hope are constructive, but I also will
acknowledge that probably can't be
answered here tonight. And I would, uh,
appreciate the opportunity to continue
the conversation outside of this in
person or an email, however.
So, the first question is what I'd like
to know what is the city the status of
the city's collective bargaining
agreement with the police. Um, and where
the public can access this
information. Um, I tried to find a
current agreement and can only find an
agreement signed by the mayor that was
due to expire in December of 2022.
Um, and my understanding is that
sometimes union contracts can continue
past their expiration date unless
they're compelled back to the
renegotiation table. So, I was just
wondering if that's the case here. Um,
in general, um, what would be the
council's plans for upcoming
renegotiations with the police union or
the police given the feedback that the
constituents you serve have given over
the past month? This is my
question. Question two, is there
potential to include the establishment
of a civilian review board in any uh and
I'll say one with actual authority
because I know that's been a question in
the re to include that in the re
renegotiations of the city and the
police.
Um, I think the mayor's comments have
made clear
that the police will not in good faith
address the community's demands if they
come from a civilian review board or
really any entity for that matter if
they don't have the proper
authority.
Um, so I'm questioning if that authority
exists at all in the city right now,
frankly, and I feel like a lot of us
are, maybe including the mayor.
So, a civilian review board with real
authority would require adequate funding
which could be tied to the police budget
to discourage attempts to undercut that
funding. It would have independent in
investigative power and access to police
records including body camera footage.
I'll say too having looked into this
that I understand that the president
that's been set in states like
Connecticut and New Jersey
where you know frankly the the biggest
power for civilian review board is sub
subpoena power and that has largely come
from state legislatores not municipal
like this. Um, but I think the important
fact to recognize is
that subpoena power isn't given unless
there's a civilian review board to give
it to. We are trying to lay the
groundwork for that. Senator, I
appreciate your comments, but we've hit
3 minutes. Um, if I may endeavor to
answer your first question and then I do
have you're on the list. Can I wrap up?
You've just very very briefly because
we've already gone over three minutes.
Okay. Yeah. I just think that if the
alternative is nothing, nothing's not
enough is is is part of the point. And
we could fund this possibly, which was
going to be my third question, with the
emergency relief funds. I I'd love to
learn more about how we can use those
funds, even if that's to replace the
police department if we do go to the
negotiating table and they don't like
the deal, you know, like I'd like to
know what those funds are for as well.
Thank you. Um just to briefly address
your first question and then I'm happy
to to respond uh in more detail because
I don't have all the answers in front of
me at the moment as well. Um but to your
question about the current collective
bargaining agreement um it has been
negotiated since then. I don't know
exactly where to find it. Uh but I can
help you with that. And the current one
is in effect through um is it 2026 Mayor
Sarati or 2020 the end of 2025
1231 2026 1231 2026 I knew it and then I
wanted to verify that I was correct. So
thank you
uh Mr. Harris our next public commenter
for this period. Yes madam president.
Our next speaker is Karen Scher.
Hi, good evening. Thanks for having me.
Um, and thanks for all that you do. I
know that it takes out a lot of time out
of your personal lives. I really
appreciate it. Um, I'm here to talk a
little bit about the groups of kids that
I've witnessed and seen. And I hate that
that's kids because Oh, my name Karen
Schlair. How about we start there? Uh,
Boys and Girls Clubs of Lancaster. Uh my
properties are West Lemon Street, Water
Street, and Duke Street. Um so back to
talking about um the groups of folks
that I've seen traveling on bikes that
have been
unsafe and this has been over the course
of the last 2 to 3 years that we've
witnessed this. I really feel like this
is a safety issue. It's a community
problem that we have to address. And I
would like to be solutiondriven. I don't
think kids need to be taught to not ride
in and out of traffic and down the
middle of the road. I think those are
basic skills that kids learn. We all
learn to not ride our bikes that way.
I've experienced groups of I keep
referring to them as kids, but I've
recently learned that they are young
adults some of them. And that's been
difficult for us to handle because we
only handle and deal with kids. We have
had on multiple occasions reached out to
some of those adults to have meetings,
to have
conversations, to find a healthy way to
have fun on bikes and not have a thrill
of danger on bikes. For those that don't
know, my office is on Vine and Water
Street. My window looks over the corner
of Vine and Water Street. The things
that I witness when I'm taking a little
break from emails and look out my window
and see the hordes of kids, young adults
popping wheelies and burning through
that stop
sign terrifies me.
actively scares me and I don't want that
on our
conscience. What the club has done, as I
said, reach out to some of the young
adults trying to come up with more
conversations. We've had one
already. We've also applied for a grant
for bike racks so that kids can safely
park their bikes at Boys and Girls
Clubs. It's the only properties I can
control. So, at our three locations,
we'll have brand new bike racks
hopefully by the spring because I do
think that that's some of the fear that
the kids have with leaving their bikes
out. Some of the bikes are quite
expensive. Um, also, we're starting a
bike riding group that will be led with
staff. Uh it will start over in the
southeast neighborhood and be led by
staff and we'll teach positive etiquette
um for kids to enjoy safe bike riding. I
see the light. Thank you. Thank you very
much. Thank you.
Our next speaker, Mr.
Harris. Next is Ricardo Calderon.
Good evening. Good evening uh everyone.
Good evening council. Good evening
fellow community members. My name is
Ricardo Calderon. Um I live in the
Willow Street area. Today I'm uh
representing the mix and would like to
speak on our relationship with the
police department. Um, and I have a few
words I like to share afterwards, but
wanted to share that we obviously know
that the relationship between the police
department and community while we're one
is very complex and that's been around
for as long as we can uh remember. Uh
narrative is really important though and
adding to that narrative really want to
share uh the powerful relationship we
have uh whether that's through the PAL
program whether that's through our work
with the police department uh through
our call to action committee which we
see one of our partners here and coming
together to really try to address the
violence in our city um whether that's
through national night out um art in the
park if you've ever seen a bunch of
kiddos uh having a really good time on
the corner of Orange and Duke uh Orange
and Prince Street that was us uh having
a really good time Uh for those of you
who are not aware who the mix is or what
we do, uh we're a nonprofit organization
that really specializes around after
school programming and out of school
time initiatives uh trying to foster
really powerful educational environments
for our young people and families. And
while I'm not here to specifically talk
about a specific issue, I do know that
um humanizing our police officers and
our young people and communities is
really important. Um we will always have
young people riding bikes and wanting to
do things. that's never going to change.
My little girl is learning how to ride a
bike right now and I'd stop her from
going into the street yesterday and
she's 4 years old. Um, what I would love
to see as a community is how we continue
to humanize these important roles in our
community and I think that starts with
building relationships. Um, and the
reason I wanted to come and speak on
behalf of the mix is because we see that
within our doors when the police
officers come into our building. We try
very hard to establish a relationship,
not seeing the officer in uniform, but
the human behind the badge. um to be
able to understand what they're going
through, to be able to understand what
young people are going through. Um so no
doubt we have many many issues that we
have to take on. Uh I just want to
encourage us whether it's through the
policies that we're looking to do,
whether it's great initiatives such as
the bike ride, um how do we continue to
find humanity in what we do and building
those relationships because independent
uh of what we try to do, young people
will be young people. And I think as
adults, it's our job to make sure that
we're um carefully building those
relationships so there's a connection um
so there's an understanding. So when
there are altercations um humans are
engaging with each other, not
opposition. Uh I think that's very very
important in our community especially uh
given the landscape of today's world
where everything is very extreme.
Everything is um on either side.
Narratives are running how we feel about
people, how we uh choose to act. So, I
really really hope that we can come
together and figure out ways uh not just
from a storytelling perspective, but
also a relationship building
perspective, how we're doing that uh for
our community and for our students in
particular, our young folks. Uh so,
really appreciate the time today. A lot
of respect for what we're all doing here
as we all play a role in this. And
again, I just want to reemphasize um
humanizing each other. We need to go
back to humanizing who we are uh and
finding our human in this space.
Appreciate you all. Thank you, Mr.
Peron.
Mr. Harris, our next speaker. Yes, madam
president. Next is Will Kefir.
Mr. Kefir, good evening. Good evening,
city council and mayor Sarra. Thanks for
having me in tonight. I will add to this
discussion. I just want to paint a
picture of some really important work
being done collaboratively between the
organization that I lead, which is
Benchmark program. We're at the
intersection of Prince and Vine, very
close to the Boys and Girls Club.
and and and so the work between
benchmark program and our local police
force in May or March of last year, we
were awarded this grant from the
Pennsylvania Commission on Crime and
Delinquency called a VIP grant, violence
intervention and prevention. It's a
three-year grant and it's beginning to
target or to support kids who have been
involved with some kind of firearm
related crime but aren't being charged.
So, at our organization, we have
pathways to support kids who have gotten
formally charged. They're incarcerated
at the Youth Intervention Center. We
have programs for them. But what we
haven't been able to serve and what we
can't do without our police department
is I can't connect with the kids who are
at that scene, who are detained, and
then who are released back home. The
police are the only ones at that
incident who know those kids. And
through this grant from the Pennsylvania
Crime Commission on Crime and
Delinquency, we now have a pathway for
police to get parent permission to
release information about those children
to benchmark so that we can provide a
one-on-one mentor for them. Now, we go
to the house, connect with parents,
connect with the kid. This is all
voluntary. No one who is detained by the
police and sent home has to come to
Benchmark. But finally, through this
proactive approach with police, we have
a chance to connect with those kids. And
I'm not sure they'd otherwise just walk
into benchmark program for services. So
I'm grateful to the police department
for doing that work. I view that as
upstream work connecting with kids
before they get a formal charge. And
statistically the kids who are at one of
those crime scenes and sent back home
without any formal charges are actually
most likely to perpetuate violence. So
we now have this chance to connect with
them and serve them and support them
when we otherwise wouldn't. And I
couldn't do that work without police.
And I don't think many people know that
we're doing that work because it's quiet
and it's small and it's not fixing all
the problems. But I think it's a start.
And I have to be clear that we could not
do that without them. And I'm grateful
to them and I want to see that work
continue. And that's all. Thank you very
much,
Mr. Harris. Our next speaker this
evening. And next speaker is Janet Sims.
Is Miss Sims here?
No. Okay. I'll call her um at the
conclusion and the uh at the second
period just in case that she comes in uh
after uh Miss Sims. Mr. Harris is Mary
Shakira.
Good evening. Good good evening and
thank you for letting me speak. Um, I
live at 239 North Concord Street in
Lancaster and I think everybody up there
knows me. I am only speaking as a person
and from
um my personal perspective. I am here
tonight because I believe that our
Lancaster City Police are good human
beings and excellent policemen. They
protect our community, but more
important, they care about public
safety. This is a public safety problem.
Kids need to learn real life lessons to
have respect for rules and laws for
everybody's safety. I am an educator
having worked with students of all ages.
I know that sometimes kids do not think
of the consequences, but imagine if they
hit someone or if a driver hit one of
them. I have witnessed kids driving
their bikes in traffic recklessly, doing
wheelies with only one tire on the
ground, moving in and out on Duke
Street, on Malbury at King again at
Charlotte and West Chestnut. These kids
are just fooling around. It's
frightening to me as a pedestrian since
I have been hit by a car and had two
broken legs. Healing takes a long, long
time with lots and lots of physical
therapy besides learning to walk again.
Public safety, to quote Mayor Ernie
Triano of Wildwood, New Jersey, listen,
this isn't a suggestion. It's the law.
We are not playing games when it comes
to the safety of others. You break the
rules, you pay the consequences. There
are actually consequences for your
actions. So, I know that the police do
an amazing job trying to get everybody
and figure it all out, but they are not
our enemies. They are here for us. So,
thank you very much for letting me
speak. Thank you, Mr. Her.
Mr. Harris, our next speaker. Next
speaker is our Mars.
Good evening. Good evening, council.
Arthur Morris, 400 block of Westchester
Street. My comments relate, as other
comments have here this evening, to the
police arrests of teenagers who were
riding bikes on North Queen Street last
month. I've previously witnessed this
behavior by youth on bikes. They were
cutting across traffic, doing wheelies,
and generally showing off their skills.
I'm sure they were having fun, but this
was not the place for it. The the
behavior was reckless and the public
safety threat to them,
pedestrians, and drivers. I want to
thank our police and the mayor for
taking this action. Such reckless
behavior must not be
tolerated. Two other comments. I believe
the police use reasonable methods to
restrain these youth, which would not
have been easy to do. These kids are in
great shape and they're quick and I
don't I don't like the fact that the
police have to put themselves in a
position where they can get hurt as
well. I do not believe they used
excessive
force. I appreciate those that spoke
about connecting our youth with police
and others to improve their lives.
However, in the meantime, I urge parents
and other adults who are associated with
youth involved to take them to the
police station, have them apologize, and
then discuss what public service they
can perform to help mitigate the
consequences they face. This can be a
learning experience when managed
correctly. Thank you very much for your
time. Thank you, Mayor Morris.
Our next speaker, Mr. Harris, is Jessica
Lopez.
Good evening. Good evening. I'm going to
present you guys.
Jessica Lopez, Lancaster City. Um, hope
everybody's having a good evening.
Let me start by
saying that this narrative that it's
okay to be on black and brown children
for not having bike lights and popping
willies in the street needs to stop. The
conversations that were had here like I
get the comments. I get the concerns.
Yes. And I love the fact that we do have
organizations like this for our kids.
But this set narrative from our
community members that would never
understand the issues of the black and
brown community that is okay to put
hands on children over riding
bikes is
crazy. Now the proposal I just handed
you guys is a proposal that was given to
the Baltimore Police Department in
regards to use of force tactics on
youth. It highlights issues of certain
tactics and why they should not be
utilized on
children. It gives
solutions. And I believe that this this
form right here could lead
youths into how to really deal with the
issues that are transpiring with the
police department and our youth. I don't
believe that we can keep
ignoring the fact that our children are
being traumatized. Harm is harm.
It don't have to be a car that hits
them. It was a cop that hit them. So,
how are they supposed to go throughout
their lives trusting police officers
now? You don't trust crossing the street
and they don't trust cops.
This narrative is
wrong. Yeah. I've come in here week
after week and yelled and screamed and
maybe you've heard me, maybe you
didn't. Now I'm giving you
solutions. We are presenting you
with
with solution after solution and beyond
just screaming and user telling us no
after no after no this can't be done.
No, these things can be done. These
things can be incorporated in that union
contract. There are things that can be
done to protect the citizens, not just
our police
officers. So, I really urge you to take
this into consideration. I really urge
you to pass this on to Chief Mendes, who
openly admitted that there were no
difference in how they treat adults than
how they treat children. And that is a
problem. He really stood here and felt
like it was okay. and he was proud of
the fact and the way his officers treat
our kids. That's not just our kids.
Y'all all have kids intertwined in this
situation somewhere that you know and
love. This could be any one of them. And
yes, we love the orgs that keep them out
the way. That still does not change how
the police officers deal with our
children. Thank you. Thank you very
much.
[Music]
I believe we have one more speaker. Is
that correct, Mr. Harris? Yes. Uh, next
is Tony Dastra.
Good evening. Good evening. Tony Dasher,
700 block of New Holland Avenue. City
Council. I fell off my bike and hurt my
leg. I've been trying to take it easy,
especially since this weekend I had to
beat Thaddius Stevens for living the
experience. Uh, get your tickets today,
by the way. Uh, and sometimes I wonder
if I have to beat Thaddius Stevens right
now, too. On account of pain, I didn't
really want to be here tonight except
for one item later under ordinances for
first reading that needed attending to
tonight. I know I can't miss it. So I So
since I needed to be here physically, I
figured I'd offer a free show in three
acts. Not living the experience. Welcome
to the Tony
Show. In this first act, why I'm
physically present at all. During the
pandemic, council had working systems to
meet and allowed participation
digitally. I'm not saying we should go
hybrid tomorrow, but I don't think it
would take much, a few steps and
planning over a couple months to get
there. When it comes to live streaming
and access, I've often thought the city
of Lancaster has been good enough postse
see-through city days. But moments like
this make me realize that good enough
often just means good enough for
now. And just because we're a walkable
city doesn't mean someone limping like
me tonight should have to come to 120
North Duke and to make their public
comments heard. And an obvious
counterpoint, just because someone can
stay home doesn't mean that they will. I
believe in a city where people can be
heard even if it when even when it hurts
to stand. The neglect of digital access,
the tools that let the meek speak and
the lame stand should trouble us all
because we've used these tools
before. We know they
work. The question is now whether we
still believe everyone deserves a seat.
Everyone deserves a seat at the table
even if they can't make it to the room.
Thank you.
Mr. Harris, do we have any additional
speakers in the first period? We do not.
Thank you. Um, just to double check,
Janet Sims, I didn't see her come into
the room. Okay,
great. We will now move into our next
item on the agenda, which is reports
requested by council. Do not believe we
have any of those tonight. Is that
correct? We do not. Thank you, Mr.
Harris. Next item is reports of
committees of council. These are the
meetings held on April 1st, 2025. Uh we
begin with the public safety committee.
Councelor Diaz uh is not here this
evening. She had one item on her agenda.
It was report to council. Public works
committee. Councelor Hirs. Thank you,
Council President. The public works
committee did meet on April 1st and
discuss five items, all of which appear
on tonight's agend uh legislative
agenda's resolutions. Resolution 27-2025
authorizes application for pen penvest
loan for the lead service line
replacement. 28 authorizes application
for penvest loan at the large diameter
water main replacement project.
Resolution 29 states the city's intent
to repay short-term financing with the
funds applied for in resolution 28 of
the water main replacement project. and
resolutions 30 and 31 authorize grant
applications for south end park
renovations and the reservoir park
master plan respectively. That concludes
the report of the public works
committee. Thank you, councelor Hirs.
Economic development councelor Vet. Uh
thank you, Mr. President. The economic
development committee did not meet.
Thank you. Finance committee councelor
Royo. Thank you, Council President. The
finance committee uh meeting or finance
committee did meet. Uh during the last
committee, we heard from director
Campbell and an update on our budget for
year end 2024 as well as the first two
months of 2025. Some of the highlights
include that for year end 2024, most
department expenses fell in low budgeted
amounts. In the general fund, the city
ended the year with a $1.2 million
surplus that will be added to reserves.
In the enterprise funds that include
water, storm water, and trash, uh we
were budgeted to end the year with
deficits. The storm water fund did end
the year with a deficit, but that
deficit was about $400,000 less than
anticipated. The trash fund ended the
year with a deficit of about $70,000
more than budgeted. The water fund was
budgeted to end the year with $160,000
deficit, but will end with a $700,000
surplus. The sewer fund was budgeted to
end the year with a surplus of $1.1
million and instead end the year with
$3.9 million surplus. That surplus will
be used to establish a sewer emergency
fund. And regarding the first two months
of the year, uh it was still too soon to
note any trends, but um at our next
budget report, we'll have a better sense
of um any trends for
2025. We also discussed administration
resolution number
25205 and administration resolution
number 26, 2025, which both appear on
the agenda later this evening. Uh that
concludes my report. Council President,
thank you very much. Council Royo,
Community Planning Committee, Council
Craig. Thank you, Council President. um
community planning did meet. We had one
item on the agenda which was
administration bill number three
amending chapter 32 to authorize the
sale of real property by real estate
agents under specific conditions which
will come up on the legislative agenda
later a little later as an ordinance for
first reading.
Thank you very much, Councelor Craig and
personnel committee. Councelor Gleas.
The personal committee did not meet.
Thank you very much. We'll now move into
our legislative agenda this evening. Our
first items are in the historic
district. Uh Mr. Harris, if you would.
Yes, Mr. President. Uh considering the
following application recommendation
from the historical architectural review
board for improvements to a property
within the historic district. One
tonight, Rob White and Stacy Coup White.
uh owners of 28 North Long Street
request replacement of five windows on
the building's facade and that
application was recommended for approval
by the historical architectural review
board. Motion to approve. Second. We
have a motion and a second. Um Council
Craig, anything additional from
community planning for this one? No,
there is not. It's pretty
straightforward. Thank you very much.
Councilors, you've all been provided
with the memo from the uh department
about the um from uh the historic
preservation specialist on this one. Are
there any council comments on the motion
to approve
from the
public hearing? None. Mr. Harris, Mr. M.
I. Mr. Roy, I Mr. Please I miss I Mrs.
H. I present Baker.
I next items are ordinances for first
reading this evening. We have one, as
councelor Craig mentioned, bill number
3, 2022, Mr. Harris, a ordinance of the
Lancaster City Council amending chapter
32, real property 2323, real property
sale of by adding a subp part B to allow
for the sale of property by the use of
realtors under specific conditions,
providing for the repeal of inconsistent
ordinances, providing for the
separability of the ordinance, and
providing that the ordinance shall take
effect in 20 days after the date of its
adoption. Thank you very much, Mr.
Harris. Again, counselors, this is a
first read this evening. Um, I'll take
any um actually I will uh councelor
Craig, if you have any additional
comments this evening. I do not have any
additional comments other than the fact
that um this bill opens up the
possibility for us to have more options
to be able to sell property when the
property does come up, which is very
rare for the city to have anything to
sell.
Thank you very much for that. Um, I'll
also add councelor Craig because there
were some questions at the last meeting
and I believe council has received
clarification on that any sale of
property would still come before council
as individual resolutions. Um, and each
time we would have the option to choose
uh the disposition and the sale uh
method of the property. Um, so the uh it
just adds an extra option for council to
then make that decision. Any additional
council comments on the uh on the
bill? Council member. Uh, thank you,
Council President. Um uh my only
question, we did answer some of these
prior uh but just wanting to make sure
that council would still have the um
authority over the process in regards to
the use of land um and making sure that
the city's interests are protected in
the sale of real property. Thank you.
Mayor Roger, do you have anything to add
on that piece? Uh thank you, Council
President. Um to reiterate your point,
this is enabling legislation that would
add a potential mechanism for the sale,
the disposition of any properties. In
the process of developing a specific
resolution about a specific property,
there would be conversation about um the
current zoning, what the future zoning
would look like related to the
comprehensive plan. Um there may be
other uh desires that the council and uh
the administration have for the future
of that. Uh there may be we may
contemplate deed restrictions similar to
what is used for other authorities
related to the sale of properties to
ensure affordability over a period of
time that matches the HUD requirements
for affordability. those things could be
um articulated in a resolution for the
dis uh position of any property uh and
they would become uh part of the sales
agreement and subsequently incorporated
into any transaction in the future. So
any realtor in if we were to opt for
this using a realtor or through um a bid
a closed bid or through a public auction
those things are all in play. This is
this is a an addition of a method,
right? So on a case- by case basis, we
would still be able to make those
decisions for each possible property.
That is correct. Okay. Thank you. Any
additional council comments for first
reading? Councelor Cle. Thank you, Madam
President. Uh one question is um how
will the funds from this sale be used by
the city?
Well, that depends on what the
priorities are for council. Um, it may
be a situation in which we want to
prioritize a particular use and we're
looking uh for a sale, but we're not
looking uh to only to sell a property
for the maximum amount of dollars. Um,
and right now the only two methods for
disposing of a property basically only
weight the sale price and not some of
the other considerations
um in the same way. So that is on a case
by case basis as well.
Thank you.
Any additional council comments for the
first reading
from the public.
Tony Dastra 700 block of New Holland
Avenue. Act two. Why this bill is bad
for the public. The ordinance before us,
administr administration bill number
three, is on its surface a procedural
update. It allows the city to sell real
estate through licensed realtors in
addition to existing methods like public
auction or bid. And I understand the
appeal. It's framed as a more flexible,
professional, and modern approach. But
the problem isn't the tool. It's the
lack of structure around how we choose
to use it. This bill delegates broad
discretion to the mayor to initiate
sales through private brokers. And while
council approval is required by
resolution, that process doesn't
guarantee meaningful public involvement.
Yes, the Sunshine Act ensures the
resolution will appear on a public
agenda, but that's a procedural minimum,
not an invitation to the public. There's
no requirement for a hearing, no notice
to neighbors, no engagement process,
despite the fact the city owns over 250
acres of land within municipal
boundaries, about 5% of the city's
footprint. And there's nothing in this
ordinance to ensure public land stays in
public service. No mention of affordable
housing, community ownership, nonprofit
partnerships, just a transactional
framework that could easily reward
access over equity. This isn't about
opposing realators. It's about opposing
opacity. And that's where the charter
comes in. Just a few months ago, the
people of Lancaster adopted a home rule
charter that began with a simple
powerful promise. We the people of city
of Lancaster, Pennsylvania aspire to
establish the foundation of an
accessible, ethical, and transparent
government. This ordinance may be lawful
under that charter, but it isn't
faithful to its spirit. Home rule wasn't
meant to free us from the constraints of
state law just so we could turn inward
and cut corners. It was meant to give us
the tools to govern more thoughtfully,
more transparently, and more in step
with the people we serve. Because public
land isn't just property, it's
potential. And if we treat this like a
line item instead of a shared resource,
we risk losing more than square footage.
We lose the opportunity to do better
together as a public. Thank you.
Any additional comments this evening for
first
reading bird? I'm not going to speak
long because I believe I addressed
council at the um committee meetings
that you had over this and my concerns
about it. I will challenge council, you
know, um we're getting ready to have
change of the guards. We're talking
about making and changing something
basically over station six, something
that would affect the whole city. And
the real reason is because we don't know
what to do with station six. At the
meeting, we discussed about nonprofits.
I want to know if council has did any
type of research to reach out to
possibilities. We talk about not having
enough space for our homeless shelter.
We have a station six that's sitting
there and we're saying we don't have
space for that. So, I want to know if
there's any other thought behind getting
rid of station six other than trying to
change the this um administration
resolution to not a resolution ordinance
which makes it law and then changing
this. Now, I think if anything needs to
be done, it needs to wait till the
administrative code is actually intact
and presented to council to approve,
which you do have to prove. And this is
something that we did in the home world
charter. Even as addressing the police,
we do have the ethics code that can
address some of the issues that people
are speaking about. So, it's all about
counsel and their due diligence and if
you're going to make the right choices
and do the right things. Thank you.
Susie Gomez, 100 block of North
Reservoir. Um, just
quickly, they would be um an extra part
of an expense on a subject line. And as
I mentioned before, it hurts to go the
extra mile to
include exactly what Darlene just
mentioned. I don't have to repeat it. I
don't have to get into it. I think she
spoke clearly. I think she spoke in
English, especially to the mayor.
There's a lot of decisions that you can
make for the people, for the citizens
that you swore no to
defend, to
serve. Very questionable.
Thank you, Miss
Gomez. Additional comments from the
public for our first reading.
Good evening. Hello, city council. Uh my
name is Richard Bowis. uh live in uh 400
block of West Marian Street and I'm here
as a resident. Uh happen to be a realtor
and uh was not aware of this ordinance,
but I just wanted to uh present to you
guys. Uh I'd recommend getting some
input uh from Lancaster County
Association of Realtors. This ordinance
may or may not make sense, but I would
use them as a resource and gain their
input before you make a decision. That's
all. Thank you.
Good evening. Hi, Brian Nelson. Uh, I
live off of Albany Circle right off
Columbia Avenue. And, um, Lancaster has
a homelessness problem and we've banned
encampments and we've pushed them out
and we are here talking about property
that we could be using to benefit those
individuals um, just so that way the
city can turn a quick profit. Um, I
think that it's um, these are options
for us. I think that opening this up to
auctions and stuff like that, um, you're
not that's not going to make housing
more affordable. It opens it up to
private equity and that's just going to
make it more expensive. So, I think that
we need to look at, you know, we have
all this land. We've been pushing
homeless people out of where they are.
We can't house them because there's not
much space. And I think that the city
needs to look more at options that could
be used to benefit those individuals
before they try to turn a profit.
Thank you.
additional comments tonight for our
first reading.
Hi, uh, my name is Aaron Dowick. I live
on the 300 block of New Del Street. I
just agree with everything everyone had
to say here. Um, we we as a city, we
have it's obvious we have an affordable
housing issue. um the apartments that
just opened on College Avenue, their
waiting list was open for like not even
a whole day and now the waiting list is
3 to 5 years long. Um that's insane.
Like I know personally at least five
people that are looking for housing and
you can't find apartments under $1,000 a
month in this city. That's not
affordable to average people. And you're
talking about selling properties for
profit of the city. Like we need
properties that normal people like me
and everyone I know can afford to rent.
The high rent prices are making it
impossible to have a path to home
ownership. Thank you. Thank you,
[Applause]
Council President, if I may. Councelor
Mad. Um, just to reiterate my question
earlier, I mean, this would give council
control over what the use of the land
would be on a case-by case basis just
like it is today. Is that correct? Yes.
And I'll also just reiterate that
council can set parameters uh for the
use and um uh there is not discussion. I
mean, I know that we're talking we're
conflating two things because this is
related to station 6 because it is a
piece of property that we've been trying
to sell. I'll just reiterate for
council's uh awareness that all of the
nonprofit housing developers were
approached about bidding on this
property. Uh we would like to see
nothing less than it become housing and
it's part of an R3 residential district.
Um we would appreciate if that were
affordable housing and we are not
necessarily looking to make a profit
from the sale of this. We are just
trying to find the best use for the
property and a buyer who will make that
happen and will not let the property
degrade or and not have the resources to
actually make a project happen um at
that site. And so uh again, this is
we're we're we're talking about two
things, but we're actually not even
ready to talk about station 6 yet
because we haven't even had this
conversation. This is about a method of
of disposal of a property for a better
use than uh it's sitting vacant right
now and the council will determine the
compensation paid to the realtor. Um but
who determines who the realtor is? So
that's a professional service and that
is uh typically under the purview of the
administration to select uh a a party in
which to sell the property. The terms
and conditions of that can be stipulated
by council if there are concerns about
um it being more than what the typical
uh um compensation would be for a
realer. But um that is a professional
service and that is typically uh done by
by uh administration. But the process of
what the future of the property is and
so on is a conversation that will need
to be had and it would probably fall
under uh councelor Craig's committee um
should we get to that point. If we
don't, we're we're going to put it out
to private bid again. Um and and I'll
just remind you that again we we had one
bid uh that was not for housing. Okay.
Thank
you. Any additional comments for the
first read? I'll just remind folks that
uh this will come up for uh possibly a
vote at our next council
meeting. Thank you. And hearing none, we
will move to our next item on the
agenda, which are resolutions this
evening. We do have several of those.
Our first is resolution number 18 2025.
Mr. Harris, a resolution of the council
of the city of Lancaster authorizing the
disposal of certain obsolete records in
conformity with retention and
disposition schedule for records of
Pennsylvania
municipalities. Motion to approve.
Second. We have a motion and a second.
Council, I'll take this in council
Diaz's um absence. Uh this is a um a
procedural resolution required under the
record retention law. Um, we required
and allow to destroy paper copies of
certain records. Um, this resolution,
I've learned, refers to approximately
seven paper boxes of records. And I do
want to confirm, as we've learned since
our last meeting, that all records
remain and are required to remain
electronically
uh, stored. So, nothing is being
destroyed or erased. So this is simply
the physical paper files uh which are no
longer required and in some cases
required to be destroyed in this certain
time period. Any additional council
comments on the resolution?
Council president councelor. Uh thank
you. Just uh reiterate that these uh
files are still stored digitally uh and
can still be requested through the right
to know act if the public would like to.
That is correct.
Additional council
funds front of
public Jessica Lopez link to PA. Um,
thank you for clarifying that. Um, may I
suggest next time that we have something
like this, we know these things in
advance. So when these questions come
up, you're not getting the response that
you're getting from the community. If
you would have known in advance that
they're digitally stored, y'all could
have been said that. And that's just
that's little things that make us feel
like you aren't doing your part in that
sense because that would have been an
easy response to everything we said last
time. It would have saved you guys a lot
of time and us a lot of frustration
trying to figure out what you wanted to
throw
away. So I mean I definitely appreciate
the clarification and that we are going
to have them digitally stored somewhere.
So, thank you. Thank you.
Additional comments on the resolution.
Good evening. Good evening. Uh Diane
Desmond. I live uh near the state police
off 30. Um I do also appreciate the
clarification that they will be stored
digitally. That was also a deep concern
of mine in terms of accountability and
uh transparency in order to mend
relationships and broken trust between
the police and the community. So I do
thank you for that clarification. Um I
did have an additional question. Um how
will obsolete be defined in these cases?
Um is it just the 7-year time? Um are
there other considerations for that
word? Um I would just like to know um
clearly how obsolete is going to be
defined, how that will be determined.
Thank you. Thank you. I can somewhat
address that although it lies a little
bit out out of my uh technical
expertise. Um but the resolution
specifically uh references um record
retention and disposition schedules. Um,
and it is
um that is set by um pardon I'm just
going through and reading here records
of Pennsylvania municipalities
promulgated that's a fun word uh by the
municipal records manual issued for the
local government records committee by
the Pennsylvania Historic Museum
commission bureau. That's a lot of words
to say that it's set at the state level.
Um, so we're meeting all the
requirements for record retention and uh
based on the disposition of these items,
uh, it sounds like every type of item
may have a different record retention.
Um, if you've ever done an audit, you
know that different things have
different retention schedules. This
sounds similar. Mayor Sarra, am I
misstating anything? That was very I've
done audits before. Um, so thank you for
that. Any additional uh council or
excuse me public comments on the
resolution hearing? None. Mr. Harris.
Mr. M. I. Mr. Roy. I. Mr. Phillips. I
Mr. Craig. I. Mr. H. I. President B.
I. Our next item. Resolution number 24,
2025. Mr. Harris. A resolution of the
council of the city of Lancaster
approving the raising of the Puerto
Rican flag to to acknowledge the start
of Puerto Rican Heritage Month as
brought forth by Lancaster City Council.
Motion second. We have a motion and a
second. Uh this resolution uh allows us
allows the approval of the flying of um
the uh Puerto Rican flag on the date
of looking for the date November 18th,
2025 with a backup date for weather of
November 19th, 2025. And this request
was put in by council Royo. Councelor
Royo, do you have anything else to add?
Nothing to add, council president. Thank
you very much. Any additional council
comments on the resolution?
And I'll just remind everyone uh that
there is a procedure for requesting a
flag to be flown at city hall. Um those
requests uh must be made at least 120
days in advance. So plan ahead and we
would love to celebrate you at city
hall. Any uh excuse me any public
comments on resolution number 24
hearing? None. Mr. Harris. Mr. Smith. I
Mr. Roy I. Mr. Please I Mr. Mr. Hi, Mr.
Hirs. Imprison Baker. I.
Next item, resolution number 25, 2025.
Mr. Harris, a resolution of the council
of the city of Lancaster, approving an
amended capital project list to be
funded by the proceeds of the city of
Lancaster general obligation bonds
series of
2018. Motion to approve. Second. We have
a motion and a second. Councelor Royal.
Thank you, council president. Uh
resolution number 25 pertains to capital
projects. So as they move forward,
funding adjustments are needed as
expenses for some projects increase and
decrease for others. Uh these
adjustments are required for approval of
council. Uh these actions are not
allocating additional funds. They just
move money away, excuse me, just move
money between previously approved
projects. Uh this specific adjustment is
for $2.3 million in the sewer fund bond.
Thank you very much. Any additional
comments from
council comments from the public on the
resolution? Darling Bird and Street,
it's my understanding that this is bonds
that we got and we didn't need them for
projects that were completed. So, this
money is left over and now council has
the power to say where that money is
spent.
So these are the 2018 general aid bonds
and some projects when they were
completed may have some funds left over.
We are required them required to move
them to other projects in the fund but
they must stay for their stated use of
the bond. So they don't go anywhere else
but the projects that were on the list
that was already on the list. Correct.
Thank you.
Any additional comments from the public
on the resolution?
So those um those funds are going into
the sewer. Is that what you said? The
sewer funds.
1.3 million. The just reiterate what you
had just said. Sorry. Yeah. These uh
funds are specific to the sewer fund
bond. Thank you. So that's going to go
on top of the 1.4 surplus and the 3.9
million. Uh this is pertaining to uh the
bond that was funding projects for the
2018 bond which is separate than than
what was stated before in the budget
update.
Okay. Thank you. Thank you.
Clarification. Did you say that the
funds are going to be used toward the
sewer projects? Uh cuz that's what she
asked and I didn't hear that. Yeah. They
were approved in the 2018. We know. And
now that there funds that are left over
and you're going to put them where in
what capital project? So that bond
approved a series of projects within
that. Right. And which where are you
going to apply that 2 million point?
What was it? 2 million.3 or something.
Yeah. So it's still staying within the
same bond. It's just going to go to
other projects that And I'm asking what
are those projects? Are they sewer and
water projects or what projects are
they? They're sewer projects. They are
sewer projects. If I could clarify,
thank you. There's a difference between
capital projects and I believe what Miss
Gomez was referencing was our operating
budget for capital projects are separate
from our operating budget. There's a
capital budget and operating budget,
right? These are for capital costs in
the sewer in the sewer and that's where
it's going to be spent. Correct. Thank
you.
Any additional comments on resolution
25?
hearing none. Mr. Harris, Mr. M. I Mr.
Roy, Mr. Cle, Mr. Krab, I, Mr. H. I, Mr.
President B.
I uh next item, resolution number 26,
2025,
a resolution of the council of the city
of Lancaster approving an amended
capital project list to be funded by the
proceeds of the city of Lancaster
general obligation bond series of
2022. Motion to approve. Sec. We have a
motion and a second. Council Roy. Thank
you, Council President. Uh this
resolution for 20 or excuse me, this
resolution is similar to resolution
number 25. Um except this is for uh this
pertains to the 2022 water fund. Um the
adjustments total $5.3
million. Thank you very much, Council
Roy. So to reiterate, funds in the water
uh for used for capital projects in the
water fund, funds that were left over
that were not used um not needed after
projects were completed and being
reallocated to other projects on the
list for the water fund. That is
correct, council president. Thank you
very much. Any additional council
comments on the resolution
from the public?
Just a quick question starting on
street. Um, so when when were these
projects due to be completed? Cuz we're
looking at 2018 bonds in 2022. So what
project in
2018 was completed and we have money
left over but we didn't use that money
toward the 2022 when we took out bonds.
So Miss Bird, as you may recall, when we
take out bonds, there's a list of
projects. These are completely separate
projects that were planned in the 2018
bond issue that we just addressed than
on the 2022 list.
So the 2018 bond project was not
completed in 2022. It just now got
completed. Is that my understanding?
There are some projects that do take
that long. Yes. Right. But we're talking
about these specific projects for the
money for resolution 26. We're talking
about specific projects in the water
fund. Right. that that just got
completed in now in 2024 and we found
out that this money is leftover. Yes,
projects do take several years, right?
And okay, let me ask you a little bit
differently, right? I don't think you're
following me. So, in 2018, we had
projects that were we took out bonds for
the sewer and those projects got
completed when that we now have this
money left over. So the this is they
only got completed in 2025, right? Okay.
Well, this one's 2022. The one before
was 2018. So the projects that got
completed, they just got completed in
2025.
Some of them. Yes. Some of these that
were funded, correct? And you have a
list of them, which ones they were, and
how much was left? Cuz maybe that would
make more sense to me.
Yes.
because that's kind of like what I'm
asking because we're borrowing more bond
money and we're having bond money left
and we're paying interest on this stuff.
You can send it to me. You don't have to
if you will if you will email that to me
that will be fine. I would like to see
that and know what projects were
completed and how much was left from
each project. Thank you. I can
definitely send that to you, Miss Bird.
Thank you. And I I do think
um I don't think director Campbell
either actually uh but director Tina
Campbell I believe you had presented
these with us. Uh could you just speak
very briefly if these are available uh
online as well?
Yes.
or someone who might know the answer.
The the uh project lists are attached as
exhibits to the resolutions that are
online. Okay. All right. So, attached
directly to the council agenda. Thank
you. Okay. Appreciate that. But still
happy to send them have them in my email
once I can get to it. I will have tabs
open. Any additional count uh comments
from the public on resolution number
26 hearing? None. Mr. Harris. Mr. M. I.
Mr. Mr. Roya I Mrs. Cles I Mr. Gra I Mr.
Hirs I pres I
next item on the agenda resolution
number 27 2025 Mr. Harris, a resolution
of the council of the city of Lancaster
authorizing the administration to
execute a financial assistance
application on behalf of the city to the
Pennsylvania Infrastructure Investment
Authority for replacement of lead water
service lines.
Motion to approve. Second. We have a
motion and a second. Council Hers. Uh
thank you, Council President. This
resolution authorizes application for a
penvest loan up to the amount of
approximately $1.7 million to go towards
confirmation and replacement of known le
service lines. This resolution
authorizes submission of the application
not necessarily to accept bloom funding
administrative requirement from pendest.
City estimates uh this this would cover
costs for approximately 108 water
service lines with an estimated cost of
uh 6 to 20,000 per line. Um, as many of
you know through our discussions here at
council, this is an unfunded mandate
from the EPA and thus the city is
starting to prepare for the massive cost
of the project. Um, the city is hoping
to have these funds available to help
defay this cost for property owners,
particularly since Penvest loans come
with much lower interest rates as was uh
stated than bond financing, but are
mostly limited to water sewer
infrastructure projects like this. also
as did um there's also grant funding
that is available um but has to be you
basically have to apply as a loan to
access that funding. Um that was also
stated by director Campbell. Um I'm just
going to end my comment by saying uh
each one of us can play a role in
keeping these costs down for the city.
The city is still inventorying water
service lines. Um so you can do so in
your basement. Um go and take a picture
of the water service line. um and send
it to the city. All those uh details are
online and um by by reporting that and
reminding our neighbors to respond to
that inventory, that will reduce the
cost of the inventory for the city. And
I just I will always take a moment to
remind folks about that.
Thank you very much, Councelor H. Uh
just a question for you because you
mentioned it and I want to put a fine
point on it. the the point of uh this
funding application uh this application
for funding is to uh complete leadline
replacement at no cost to residents.
Correct. Thank you. Um and that you know
could range depending on my
understanding is could range depending
on what the nature of that you know
because there's the poting procedure
which is a more expensive way of
figuring out what the what the material
is. Um, and then there's, you know, from
that to the full replacement, that's
that range of the 6 to 20,000 cost that
would be covered for the for these.
Great. Thank you. Any additional council
comments on the
resolution from the public?
You say there's going to be no co start
darling bird and street no cost to the
residents but if it's a loan because
right now you're applying for a loan
it's not a grant. So if we don't get a
grant where there be other action by
council to vote on if it's a loan
because if it does become a loan that is
going to be a cost to the residents. No,
I'm not denying that at all. What I'm
saying is that in this particular case,
what we're hoping to have these funds
available for is actually assisting
homeowners with the replacement of the
lead water service line. Yeah, that's
what I meant when I said no cost. I
didn't mean that there's no cost. I
mean, obviously, we're, you know, this
is $1.7 million in debt financing. Um,
there's a cost with that. It's it's what
I was trying to say is that on an
individual basis, we're trying to make
these funds available for homeowners
because it is an unfunded mandate. So,
any money that we can get in to help
property owners that might not be able
to handle, you know, a
$20,000 water service line imp
placement, that's why we're trying to
get this money in. Right. So, but it's
going to be a loan, but the application
itself is for a loan or for a grant. The
application is for a loan and by doing
that that opens up the opportunity for
grant funding from Penvest. Is that
correct? Okay. Uh, director Tina
Campbell's not Yes. So, right. So I mean
I just want to clarify that because if
we're getting a loan there is going to
be a cost to the taxpayer
who's going to pay right and okay yes
our rate payers uh may see an impact if
this is a loan not a grant that's
correct let me just question so I don't
have to get up again and so the purpose
of applying for two separate um
applications that reason is because I
know we have an application fee why
can't we not combine them both for one
application for penned vest. Um I think
it's just because of the nature of these
two projects are totally different. Um
like one is related to the interior
service line and then the other is for
the water main that is going from the
Susuana to the treatment plant from the
treatment plant to point reservoir and
then to the distribution network. Right.
So it's not a guideline through Penvest
that we can apply for one and get and
only pay one application fee instead of
applying for two separate applications
and paying two separate application
fees.
Padbest uh requires two separate
applications. Okay, that's what I was
asking.
If there was a way we could it would be
nice, but they don't allow it. And if I
recall correctly, I think that's the
city is trying to do that because by
focusing on specific neighborhoods where
there's a high number of known service
lines that need to be replaced that
those could be lost together to exactly
what you're saying like reduce that fee
so we don't have to pay much time and
plot. Right. And just for the public,
how much is the application fee for
Pennst?
I don't know the answer. Uh this Oh,
okay. Director Campbell Steven Campbell
may have that answer.
[Music]
Hi, thank you very much for the
question. I honestly do not know what
the fee is. It varies by application and
by the magnitude of the cost and it's
not necessarily the same percentage for
every for every uh application.
Thank you, Dr.
Campbell, any additional comments from
the public on resolution number
27, Miss Gomez?
And just to clarify, it's only for 108
service lines in the city. That was the
estimate given by this. It could be
possibly more or less depending on how
it shakes out, but that's the estimate.
Yes. Yeah. We we knew 10 years ago that
this was an issue. It should have been
done 10 years ago. It's sad that we had
to wait this long and strain the
taxpayers
to crunch up these numbers and be
responsible for this debt.
But I really need a copy of the 108 um
service lines of homes that are going to
be receiving this because 108 service
lines is that just are you saying within
the home or service lines throughout the
city? Through throughout the city and to
be clear, Miss Gomez, the city has been
updating these lead service lines. This
is uh I guess being expedited that
process because of of the deadline.
You're already past the deadline. That's
why because they basically accelerated
the timeline on this process. Mhm.
And added the interior lines as well. I
didn't I don't know if you want to speak
to that, Mayor.
Just just to say the city has been
replacing lead laterals off the water
lines for decades which is why we have
so few. The the new law that has been
passed both accelerates the remaining
replacement of those uh lead lines those
ladders of which there are less than 1%
out of the 50,000 lines that are across
our water distribution service area.
What is new is that this uh utilities
are now responsible for the line that is
coming from the curb into the house.
That was only ever contemplated as being
private property and under the Biden
administration that law was changed. And
so the city has been doing uh the work
that it has been required to do to
replace all of our laterals. What is new
is the replacement of what would have
been previously understood as private
property. That is now our job. That is
now a a burden that rateayers will have
to carry because there is not enough
federal grant money to meet the demand
across the country. And this is a point
of advocacy uh through the water council
and US conference of mayors and other
groups that I'm affiliated with because
I do understand the impact to our rate
payers.
But it has but it was a problem. It's
always been a problem.
And it's I'm sorry.
When's the dead when when is the
deadline?
Hurse.
Years to replace. Sorry. 10 years to
replace the lens. No. The deadline that
you have years. We're We're already at
the 10th year then. No, it's it's from
now. It's from now. It starts 10 years
from now. Okay.
Thank you, Miss Go. Thank you. Any
additional comments from the public on
resolution number 27?
Hearing none. Mr. Harris, Mr. M. I, Mr.
Roy. I, Mr. Please. Hi, Mr. Hi. Mr. H. I
present. I
The next item is resolution number 28,
2025. Mr. Paris, a resolution of the
council of the city of Lancaster
authorizing the administration to
execute financial assistant assistance
application on behalf of the city to the
Pennsylvania Infrastructure Investment
Authority for construction of the
Susuana large diameter transmission
mains.
Motion to approve second. Have a motion
and a second. Councelor Hirs. Thank you,
Council President. This resolution
authorizes an application for a penvest
loan up to the amount of
$49,293,000 to go towards the Sesame
large diameter transmission means both
phase two, the finished water
transmission main, that's the one that
goes from the water treatment plant to
the Oyster Point Reservoir. Um, and
phase three, which is going from the
treatment plant from the river to the
treatment plant. um fa relating to phase
2. Um that transmission mean is beyond
its useful life on paper. Um so it's an
urgent concern uh priority for the city
to address it replacement. Penvest
requires projects to be shovel ready
before we can apply for financing for
the project. So because this project is
still working through permits design and
that process takes years for projects of
this scale, uh the city may pursue
interim bank financing until the project
can be fully funded by Penvest. Um this
will help the city avoid multi-year
interruptions in the process of
replacing this water man. Interim
financing would mainly be for pieces of
equipment materials uh needed to make
sure that the project doesn't get
stalled given how critical it is and
also the fact that there's a deadline on
a $3 million grant to purchase equipment
to start this project. City wants to
ensure once construction begins on the
project it doesn't stall at any point
due to lack of financing or uh
disruptions with supply chain etc. Thank
you very much councelor Hirs. Any
comments from council on resolution
number 28? Council President, if I may.
Councilman. Thank you, Council
President. I just want to um maybe uh
questions for Director Campbell. Uh the
the inter the intermittent financing as
well as the penest loan. Um we've looked
at the budgetary impact it would have um
and it is aligned with our projections.
Ye. Yes. Um so we had included this um
when we were looking at the 2025 bond um
last month. We included this in the
overall projections. So it would have
been part of the graphs that you saw in
those projections.
Thank you very much counc. Any
additional council comments on the
resolution
from the public on resolution 28? Okay.
and clarify again how much did you say
you're looking for for this um
resolution? This resolution would
authorize an application up to
49,293,000.
49 million. And this is in addition to
the 41 million bond that council
approved just couple um councils ago. Is
that correct? Correct. This is for a
different project, but yes, for a
different project. I thought that was
for the water mane as well.
The large diameter water mane. Yeah. The
from the grass that we had when we did
the bond um uh presentation, it had the
pen that's loan in gold or in a
different color and that was not a part
of the original bond, but that budget
tear impact was still projected out over
the the the life of the bond. We talked
about it at that. So we're talking about
maybe $90 million we will be borrowing
and taxpayers will be footing that bill.
Rate payers uh in the water tax
taxayers will pay the city that are the
90 million utility. Yes. Even for the
penvest loan. Correct. Okay. Okay. Very
good.
Infrastructure is extremely expensive.
This is I have learned this. Uh it
really is and and since we do have 10
years and I did attend the water meeting
that uh the public works department put
on. It was a very good meeting, very
informative. I want to encourage members
of the public when the council or when
the city does put on these meetings to
attend because you do learn a lot and I
know that they are working on a plan for
the future, a comprehensive plan that
may extend our timelines possibly. So,
while we're saying we only have 10 years
now, we did learn that that time could
be extended. So, I think council really
needs to consider before they vote about
the cost that you're putting on and like
you said the water companies, the rate
payers and we know that the city pays
the highest rate right now and we know
that's going to be looked into but you
really need to consider that because
government has set up where we can look
at other ways of getting meeting the EPA
requirements and doing that at a lower
cost to the rateayer.
and extending our time so that the 10
years could be extended depending on the
comprehensive plan that the water did I
understand that well right if if I may
miss bird thank you miss bird m um just
to clarify you're you were talking about
two different things I am so
appreciative that you went to the
combined sewer overflow meeting which
I'm going to actually give in my talk
about in my mayor's report that is
different than the 10-year timeline for
the lead and copper rule So, we're
talking about three different things
tonight. We're talking about
infrastructure replacement, which is the
42inch main, which is what is being
considered now. We're talking about the
lead line replacement, which is an
unfunded mandate that is separate. That
is another cost. And then we're also in
a few minutes, I'm going to talk about
the combined sewer overflows and a
long-term control plan, which is all
three of those things are different.
Yep. Thank you. Additional comments from
the public on resolution number 28.
Mayor, I'm listening to what you're
saying. You're talking about three
different things, but we are also
talking about um funding that was uh
available from two to 2018 to
2022 that um is being moved over into
administrative projects or other other
you know projects that could be used for
purposes such as the water
man. You can't use it for that. Are you
speaking about the funds left over in
the bonds? As far as the bonds, yeah,
which you're going to get um her a copy
of where that's going to for those items
on those list. We can't change the bond
the allocations of those funds mid, but
you could use it for some of that so
that the bond can decrease.
No, that's not true.
You can't.
So the 2018 project list I think is an
attachment. I think Mr. Harris just
mentioned that it's available on the
website with the materials for the
meeting. It lists the project from 2018.
That was for the sewer fund. Then
there's the water fund. Those were
projects from 2020
2022. Those are projects that are listed
in the attachment um for the materials.
What we are talking about are different
projects than what is on either of those
lists.
I understand that, but projects with
funding left over should be used by
council for specific reasons to not
burden the taxpayers so
much, you know? I mean, there there's
got to be other ways that you can use
that. We're not the experts. We're the
taxpayers. We pay you the salary so that
you can figure it out. I mean, just try
to make it make sense. If there's
funding available here that can be used
for anything else other than specific
projects that she's going to submit
documents to to Miss Bird about, why not
use it for these things so that you
can't continue to burden the taxpayers?
I mean, we're already seeing so much of
a burden. I understand and appreciate
your question and I I I hear you, but
when we issue a bond, when we take out
indebtedness, we must submit a project
list and we can't change that midstream
legally. Legal. No, no. Legally. Yeah.
So, I hear you and appreciate what
you're asking, but we're not able to
take the funds out of the bond and use
it for something that we didn't say
we're going to use it for in the first
place. But they're asking you to
consider the amount. And I heard her say
that to have to to consider the numbers.
That's all I'm asking too.
Any additional comments from the public
on resolution 28?
Hearing none. Mr. Harris. Mr. Smith. I.
Mr. Roy. Hi. Mr. Sweet. I Mr. Craig. Hi.
Mr. H. I pres.
Uh, next item is resolution number 29,
2025, Mr. Harris. A resolution of the
council of the city of Lancaster to make
declaration of official intent to
reimburse short-term financing used for
the Sesuana large diameter transmission
mains project with funds received from
the Pennsylvania Infrastructure
Investment
Authority. Motion to approve. Second
again. Have a motion and a second.
Councelor H. Thank you, Council
President. This resolution is related to
or resolution 29 is related to
resolution 28 and that it pertains to
the penvest busting pen vest funding um
that's being applied before that we were
just talking about. Um as stated the
city may need to utilize short-term
financing um in the amount of 27 million
to keep the Susuana large diameter
transmission means projects moving. Um,
and this resolution fulfills
administrative requirement from Penvest
to have a resolution stating that the
official intent of the city is to pay
down this short-term uh financing when
the Penvest funds are received. So, in
other words, stating our intent to
refinance the short-term financing with
more favorable lower interest Penvest
funds when we receive that. That's a
requirement from Penvest and this
resolution meets that requirement. Thank
you very much, councelor Hirs. I think
we had a conversation during committee
um about the types of things that we
could do in the interim and how we could
keep the projects moving, namely
purchasing equipment um and the impacts
of waiting to purchase that equipment
because of inflation and the tariffs and
the unknown uh but known impact that
it's going to the prices are going to go
up. So by doing this we get ensure the
best rate on purchasing that equipment.
Is that a correct characterization of
director Campbell's comments? That's my
understanding. He's nodding from the
back. Thank you. Council comments on the
resolution
from the public on resolution 29
hearing. None. Mr. Harris. Mr. Smith. I
Mr. Roy. I Mr. Please. I Mr. R. I Mr. H.
I President B. I
resolution number 30 is our next item.
Mr. Harris, a resolution to the council
of the city of Lancaster authorizing the
filing of an application for funding
through the Department of Conservation
and Natural Resources Community
Conservation Partnership Program in the
amount of
$1,385,035 to be used for South End
Park. Motion to approve. Second. We have
a motion and a second. Council Har.
Thank you, Council President. This
resolution authorizes the city of
Lancaster to apply for $1.385 million in
grant funds from DCNR's Community
Conservation Partnership Program to go
towards improvements at South End Park.
Uh these funds would go toward upgraded
play equipment, a multi-purpose field,
basketball court upgrades, improved ADA
access, water play, new fencing, and
improved seating and lighting at South
End Park. This grant would uh the city's
estimating would cover 50% of that cost.
And there are other grant funding
sources the city's waiting to hear back
on, such as the local shares account um
that could go towards this project.
Thank you very much. Any council
comments on resolution 30?
from the
public hearing. None. Mr. Harris. Mr. M.
I. Mr. Royer. Hi, Mrs. Please. I Mr.
Craig. Hi, Mr. H. I and President
Bickett. I.
Our next item is resolution number 31,
2025. Mr. Harris. A resolution of the
council of the city of Lancaster
authorizing the filing of an application
for funding through the Department of
Conservation and Natural Resources
Community Conservation Partnership
Program in the amount of
$74,960 to be used for Reservoir
Park. Motion to approve second. We have
a motion and a second. Council Hirs.
Thank you, Council President. This
resolution authorizes city of Lancaster
to apply for
$74,960 in grant funds um from the
community conservation partnership
program as mentioned um to go towards
preparing a master plan for Reservoir
Park. Improving Reservoir Park was
identified as a high uh priority in the
city's parks master plan and as referred
to in this resolution, Reservoir Park
has a lot of potential and a lot of
potential uses and so for these reasons,
the city would like to prepare a master
plan for Reservoir Park.
Thank you very much, Councelor Hirs. Uh,
additional comments from council on
resolution
31, from the public.
Darling Bird, um, I heard you say on the
other one for South End Park that you
were looking for a match from other
grants. Does this require a match?
Uh, director Tina Campbell is waving or
is nodding yes. And where do we plan on
getting that match for this?
That I do not know. Um, okay. So, we're
going to approve, council is going to
approve that we apply for a grant and we
don't know where the money is coming
from to match it yet. Is that correct?
Is that what I'm hearing? if you can
speak to that.
Uh for this resolution 31, um it's
coming from the the 2025 bond funds that
were just approved.
Thank you. So, we already borrowed the
money for the match for this project
through the bonds.
additional comments from the public on
resolution 31
hearing. No, Mr. Harris. Mr. I, Mr. Roy,
I, Mrs. Please, I, Mr. I, Mr. I,
President B.
I, we have reached the end of our
legislative agenda this evening, which
will move us into our second public
comment period. It's open for comments
on issues that were not on the agenda.
Again, duration of comments is limited
to 3 minutes. Per speaker, please begin
with your name and your residence uh
your block of residence for our public
record. Uh good evening. My name is
Taylor Entline Manheim Burrow. But um I
am my name is Taylor Interline. I'm
reading this statement on behalf of John
Minda uh the founder of the Black Voter
Outreach Network of Pennsylvania.
Mayor Sarra, I am addressing you
directly this evening because your
administration is overseeing a
regression in public trans transparency
that is deeply troubling and quite
frankly unacceptable. Just last quarter
in quarter 4 of 2024, the Lancaster City
Police Department published a use of
force report that included data
disagraded by race and age. That report
told an important story. 36% of use of
force cases involved Latino residents,
20% involved black residents, and seven
incidences involved minors, children.
That level of detail helped the
community understand who is most
impacted by use of force and provided a
foundation for meaningful oversight.
Now, mayor, those details are gone. The
recently updated dashboard on the police
department's website is cleaner, but
that is where progress stops. It strips
away the most essential data points.
There is no racial or ethnic breakdown,
no information on minors, and no access
to previous quarterly reports. The graph
presented on the page is visually
misleading and hard to interpret. No
explanation was provided. No public
update was issued and the change was not
even disclosed during the April 1st
public safety committee meeting where
Chief Mendes spoke at length. To make
matters worse, the number of reported
use of force incidents for quarter 4,
2024 has quietly dropped from 39
incidences previously documented to 29
now shown on the dashboard. That's a 25%
decrease with no explanation. What
changed? Are these incidences being
reclassified? Are we using a new metric?
Are some incidents no longer being
counted? If we can't answer those
questions, then the public can't trust
the data. We are calling this what it
is, a roll back of transparency in the
middle of a community crisis around
policing. It is one thing to issue
talking points about accountability, but
it is another thing entirely to quietly
remove the very information that allows
for accountability to exist. When you
withhold data, you withhold the truth.
And that decision breaks the fragile
trust between city hall and the
communities who are asking to be seen,
heard, and protected. Mayor Sarra, you
have said that the police oversight
boards have no power. There are cities
across this country, including here in
Pennsylvania, that have past civilian
review boards with investigative
authority and subpoena power. Lancaster
can do the same. The real question is
whether the political will exists. In
closing, I respectfully submit the
following questions to you and ask that
you respond in writing to the public
before the next council meeting. One,
who made the decision to remove the
demographic and age related data from
the police use of force reports? Two,
why were city council members in the
public not informed about this change?
Three, will your administration commit
to restoring the full disregated
reports, including past quarters, for
public view? public review four. If not,
please be brief. I gotcha. If not,
please explain why this data is no
longer appropriate or relevant for
public access. And five, do you believe
the data transparency is essential for
public accountability. Thank you for
your time and we expect honest answers
and real action. Thank you.
Good evening. Hi, uh Brian Nelson, uh
for uh Pion Circle Drive. Um, so I
understand while public safety remains a
concern, um, the handling of children
should not result in an incident of
police misconduct or excessive force.
And it shouldn't be up to the department
to decide if it was excessive force.
That's up to us in the community. It is
my belief that um, community engagement
should be done through the office of the
mayor or city council, not the
department. That consolidates power with
them, not us. So, I have a pop quiz for
you guys. Uh, the Citizen Police Review
Board is an independent agency within
blank created in 1997 to investigate
citizen complaints about improper
conduct by the Blank Bureau of Police
through a referendum um through a
referendum. Um, I would let you know
that that city is the city of Pittsburgh
here in Pennsylvania. And perhaps it is
time that we demand a referendum
ourselves. It's not in the CBA, but it
didn't matter to the people of
Pittsburgh. And better yet, they offered
the um their citizens to join those
meetings by Zoom.
Citizen advisory boards exist and they
have been done some with genuine
authority. Pittsburgh is an example.
Now, it can't be done with no authority
as in Philadelphia, but they have been
done. I think that this is something you
guys really need to look into because it
sounds like you saying that this is
something that's not possible just
sounds like an excuse to not do it or
not put in the effort to work with us.
We've already seen that the Lancaster
City Police isn't willing to come to the
table. I have zero faith in their
community engagement office if it's not
done through citizens. Uh the there's
nothing we can do to do anything better
in our community if you guys aren't
bringing us to the table. We've heard
from a number of groups today that can
contribute to community policing as
well. Some of them have left and the
people who came to speak in favor of the
police are now suddenly gone. But
however, I just want to let you know
that since 1994, the US Department of
Justice has provided grants to over
13,000 law enforcement agencies to
support community policing initiatives,
highlighting the importance that it has
in our justice system. These are things
that you guys can do. We've just told
you what it is. I expect you guys to
actually make an effort to look into it.
Thank you.
Good evening. Good evening. Uh my name
is Duncan Hopkins. I live in the
northeast part of the city. Um, and I
want to start out with a question uh
addressing some of the comments uh
earlier in this uh earlier in this
meeting as well as last week. Why are we
spending our time characterizing these
kids who were assaulted by police
officers as violent? They were riding
their bikes without lights, which is a
civil offense and not a criminal one.
Yet, in the chief's presentation last
week, and in some comments from folks
here tonight, we've been treating these
kids like
criminals. Traffic safety is important.
10 years ago, I was biking to work when
I was hit by a car just half a block
from here, and I was very lucky not to
be seriously injured. I also was riding
with bike lights on, and it was
daylight. I've had plenty of close
calls, so I certainly understand the
need for safety. every single person in
this room does. But that's not what we
need to focus on tonight. What we need
to focus on tonight is that when the
police enforce the laws on the books,
they need to do so in an appropriate
manner. What took place on March 2nd was
a clear as day example of police
brutality. I dare anyone to watch that
video in full, listening to the screams
of those kids who are afraid they might
join the long list of minors who were
murdered by a cop. That encounter was
unacceptable and the consequences for
riding bikes without lights should not
be being pinned to the ground by an
officer with a history of misconduct.
I'm speaking about Officer
Hatfield. Last week, Chief Mendes stood
up here to give a presentation on police
use of force. And while I have many
thoughts, two main things stood out to
me. First, the chief spent a long time
talking about how use of force reports
are reviewed within the department and
no time at all on whether and how
discipline would be passed on to the
offending officer. I think he said and
discipline may be applied if ex uh if
it's acceptable. That was it. It is
unacceptable that he declined to speak
about officer discipline in his report.
Second, every single council member had
the opportunity to ask the chief
questions. Some counselors used that
opportunity to ask about increased
transparency, oversight, and a different
use of force policy for minors. However,
other counselors decid declined to use
this rare opportunity to ask questions
in a public forum. For counselors to
give up the opportunity to ask Chief
Mendes, the tough questions that the
community has been asking for a month is
frankly insulting.
And lastly, I'm tired of the back and
forth. I'm tired of the excuses. And I
wish that this body would spend its time
trying to find solutions instead of just
waiting for the storm to blow over. You
all have difficult jobs. And I get that,
but you signed up for it. And you signed
up to represent your community. We have
a real opportunity to change our city
for the better, and it is disheartening
to see my city government prioritizing
quiet over justice. Chief Mendes has
said multiple times that the community
has needs to come to the table. We're
here. It's time for this council, Mayor
Saraji, and Chief Mendes to listen.
Thank you very much,
[Applause]
Tony Dastra, New uh 700 block of New
Holland Avenue. Act three, a vision for
public involvement. If acts one and two
were about access and process, this
final part is about voice, about
creating spaces where the community can
engage with institutions that serve
them. Yesterday, I introduced online a
draft ordinance to establish a community
police review board. This board would
function in an advisory capacity without
disciplinary authority focusing on
reviewing policies, procedures, and
patterns to provide recommendations
aimed at enhancing public safety and
trust. This model isn't unprecedented.
The Philadelphia in Philadelphia, the
Citizens Police Oversight Commission
operates similarly and has subpoena
power, offering recommendations that led
to policy changes within the police
department. While it didn't have
disciplinarian power, its influence
contributed to reforms. The goal here is
not to undermine law enforcement, but to
build a bridge between the police and
the community through transparency and
dialogue. By identifying areas for
improvement and suggesting policy
enhancements, such a board can play a
vital role in fostering mutual respect
and
understanding. With council members up
for election and others seeking higher
office, the direction we choose now will
shape the future of public safety in our
city. This draft ordinance is a starting
point open for discussion and
refinement. I've pushed the boulder. You
decide whether it is up a hill or down
the hill. The essential question is
whether we are committed to creating
avenues for meaningful community
participation and shaping the policies
that impact us all. Anyway, that's all
for tonight folks. Thanks for tuning in
to the Tony Show. See you next time.
Hey D. Good evening. Diane Desmond again
off Route 30 by the State Police. We've
heard some positives tonight about the
police department um by members of the
public, but I'd like to be clear that
whatever positives may exist do not
erase the concerns that the community
has voiced and the shortcomings of the
police department. I do find it
interesting and frankly disturbing that
most members of the public who felt
frightened by these youth and advocated
for harsh punishment were white. As a
white person addressing members of
council and members of the community,
many of whom are white, I urge you to
sit with the discomfort of my
observation here tonight. Use that
discomfort to reflect and appreciate how
frightened these youth feel when facing
use of force from an armed officer. Are
these feelings of fear
comparable? We are still deeply
concerned about the policing of youth
and the disproportionate use of force
against black and brown youth, which I
would like to clarify and acknowledge is
a nationwide issue that Lancaster is not
separate from.
Can we receive verbal confirmation that
the proposal from Baltimore on the
policing of youth will be reviewed,
considered, and an update on your
decision will be given to the public
verbally during an upcoming city council
meeting. And I would also like to
further know by which date. Thank you.
Good evening.
Evening. Uh, Brianna Sinvage, um, block
of 700 block of Marietta. Um, this is my
take on April 1st. Um, the Lancaster
community showed up yet again to city
hall to demand the end of police
brutality. This time, we heard police
chief Menddees give off an give an
off-topic report that blatantly ignored
our demands and attempted to shift blame
for his department's egregious use of
force against teen bike riders on March
2nd on to the community. His
presentation was filled with irrelevant
stats and policies which addressed none
of the tangible concerns and actual
demands. Yes, I don't think that Chief
Menddees presentation was random. He
went on and on about gun seizure data
emphasized on teens and early 20s,
sending a clear message that the police
still are operating under the assumption
that black and brown bodies are guilty
until proven innocent and armed until
proven otherwise. This is a thinly
veiled attempt to blame victims and
alienate um and alleviate any police
accountability. Chief Menddees stated
during the community outcry that public
safety is a two-way street. Mendes is
correct, but neglects the two key
points. The community showed up and
offered actionable demands that were
laid out and continue to be laid out.
Building trust takes time, patience, and
a willingness to be wrong. none of which
were demonstrated by Chief Menddees nor
the mayor during this committee meeting.
During doing trust means opening up the
floor to residents split directly to
those who have power, including Chief
Menddees. We were not given that
opportunity, and so I don't believe him
when he says public safety is a two-way
street and involves all of us. In
addition to denying the rights of
citizens to speak truth to power, he
failed to acknowledge the community's
pain for decades of injustice and
mistrust from racist policies and
policing. This pain cannot be erased by
patting yourselves on the back for a few
years of doing better. The onus of chain
falls on the shoulders of those in
powers. If residents are not engaged
with police events, the answer is not to
take personal demands um personally and
demand the residents show up. It's to
open up a safe form to ask why and what
can be done. Police brutality should
never happen. But it does. And the
answer is not to shift blame but um or
listing harmful statistics of
justification of use of force but to ask
why. Why couldn't train officers handled
these citations such as the incident on
March 2nd and what can be done to
prevent future situations of police
brutality from occurring. Abram X Kendi
states pain is usually essential to
healing. When it comes to healing
America of racism, we want to heal
America without pain. But without pain,
there is no progress.
At the end, it was clear police Menddees
and the mayor said members and some
members of city council were unwilling
to wade into that pain and join us on a
two-way street to healing and policy
reform. Without addressing our pain or
demands, we will continue to be two
ships passing in the night instead of
meeting on an equal playing field out
beyond right doing and wrongdoing. Until
open discussion and honest cooperation
can be had, we the community are left to
wrestle with knowing we have a long
fight ahead of us. Thank you. Thank you.
Good evening. Good evening.
Uh, my name is Betty Jones, South
Sand, 200 block of South Street, I
should say. Okay. I'm here again to talk
about the trash situation that occurred.
um about a month or so ago back
um from one the whole block of um the
whole southeast section 200 100 block
200 all the way down to the 400 block we
receive
um citations I would call it um for
trash which I came here before and I
spoke about it and I even showed
pictures when I received received the
uh citation. I called and the person I
spoke with, she told me that someone had
called and complained about it. Okay. I
I took pictures and if you can see
yourself, it was it was windy, so trash
was blowing all over the place. Anytime
trash can come from 100 block all the
way down to the 400 block, I know
everyone did not all of a sudden just
put trash out or did not move trash. So,
I'm coming here again to counselors to
ask for your help. That's why I came
because um I don't usually come out and
do things like this, but this is
important to me. and they they told us
we have to pay
$225 plus a
$200 fee now. So that
$225 that is due for each um tenant or I
should say owner in the 200 um in the
southeast area. So I just want to know
what um comp is going to do about this
and you know to help us. I say no us.
It's not just me, but our whole section,
you know, our whole block from the 100
all the way down to the 400 block. You
guys are here. I'm coming to you because
you supposed to be here to fight for us.
So, this is what I'm coming for some
kind of
results. Thank
you. Any additional comments for this
period? Let's go.
Yeah, it's shameful to be up here at
this podium when we didn't select this
job. We ask that you represent the
people for this position. It's shameful
that we have to be look at on a psych a
psychological standpoint because you're
used to psychologically digesting a
patient. Um, and things are just being
overlooked such as Betty's trash
issue. You don't have an answer for her?
I've been
consider Okay. Well, it's my time. So, I
wish Art Morris was here so I can just
clearly state that. Has anyone ever seen
the one-wheel bikers that are cross
throughout our streets that basically
interfere with traffic? They run in and
out of cars. They're they they I know
you all seen them. They It's one wheel
bike and there's a bunch of them and
they go all over the street. They do not
follow the
rules. So for Art Morris to stand here
and talk about our children not using
specific things that maybe neighborhood
engagement could have been uh targeting
to to to help teach our kids about bike
safety because of neighborhood
engagement. There there's so many
different types of resources that we,
you know, that we have that we're not
getting from you guys. Such as a simple
question about a trash
issue. She she didn't have to come here.
You don't think she's old enough? She
should be home
resting. And you
too, you know, the city has become this
is not a metropolitan area. You are
forcing this city to be a metropolitan
area. Therefore, we're this square block
radius that we have is being disrupted
on all sides and all levels. Our kids,
they are used to going into the streets.
We have bikers, we have onehe bikers
going all over the streets. I don't
understand it. I I I I just don't
understand. And then lastly, Harrisburg
adopted a bill, Mayor Sarra. They
adopted the bill that was given to you
guys and it's in the mayor's hands. This
bill can be passed. It's up to Mayor
Sarra. The burden stands on
you. You can make changes in this city.
You just choose not
to. Karen Schultz from the Boys and
Girls Club has she she sits in her her
desk and she looks out the window and
sees these things happening. But is she
sending out brochures? Is she sending
out invitations or do the Boys and Girls
Club have any meetings about bike
safety? She's been sitting there for 2
years. Yeah, I haven't had a flyer yet.
I'm pretty sure if I go around the block
with Benchmark with the other gentleman
that introduced this new V1 prevention
program, he probably doesn't even live
in the city. Mhm. Not only does he not
live in the city, he probably hasn't
even had a chance to walk four blocks
down the road to even speak to the
people about his prevention plan. But he
got a he got a grant for it, right?
We've got three. Yeah, I understand
that. But have some respect for us. Stop
looking at us with this scare tactic and
the psychological review thing. And
we're tired of it. Answer questions. get
things done. Thank you, Mr. Blacks and
brown kids should not have to go through
this. This is too much. You've gone over
3 minutes and there is others. This is
too
much. Miss Lopez, Jessica Lopez,
Lancaster City. Um, I do have a I kind
of want to have a little exchange real
quick if you will bear with me. Um what
is like when you guys come in, you take
office,
um you like have like a ethics oath,
right? Like what you hear in your
chambers, what you deal with on the
dayto-day in these council meetings,
like how you handle certain things. And
I wish Jana Diaz was here for what I'm
about to say because I I'm very very
disgusted that every time she leaves
these chambers, she jumps on her phone
and starts to attack people, but doesn't
say anything from these seats. And it
bothers me. Last week, like my my
emails, like what she said about me and
text messages aside, I really don't
care. I'm grown. But last week, she went
online after she left council chambers
and made a statement about counselor
Amed that provoked racist comments about
his religious practices and was a direct
attack that was so
unnecessary. Like I I I really really
need to know what is supposed to be
becoming of our council
members and what disciplinary matters
happen when things like this transpire
because why does she keep being
allowed to do things like this to people
and sit in that seat and get paid by the
members of this community? They all do.
M but do they go online and publicly
attack people's race, where they're
from, and what their religion is? Are
they sending text messages at 12:12 in
the morning asking why constituents are
coming up here and demanding
results at this
point? Why do we keep allowing her to
finish out her little term here? It's
distasteful to the community. It should
be disrespectful to each and every one
of you at this point. And what what gets
done? Was there even a conversation had
with her after the last situation that
transpired on social media? Cuz I have
the screenshots.
May I respond to that, Miss Lopez? Thank
you. Um, first of all, I agree that the
comment was um it was racist. It was
racist and disgusting. Yes. Uh, second,
I couldn't see it because she has me
blocked. She has me blocked too.
Somebody sent it to me. Um, and to your
question about what disciplinary action
is possible. Uh, she reports to all of
you. She doesn't report to me. She
doesn't report to the mayor. She reports
to the voters. So, what can I mean
outside of her already being about to be
on her way out cuz she dang sure ain't
about to be our mayor. Um, what what
what can we do intermittently to get her
out of that chair cuz she don't belong
there. I would like to have a longer
conversation about this, but D just
speaking generalities that I know it's
very difficult to remove a municipal
government member in the state of
Pennsylvania. It's a state matter, but
um yes, that's my short version of that
answer and that but I do hear what
you're saying. No. And I appreciate that
and I'm not gonna say much more, but
that speaks to the people watching on
live to really really pay attention to
who we putting in these seats that we
can't remove once they get there.
Thank you. Thank
you, Darlene Bird, 200 block of South
Street G. Um, that was a good statement.
As we have these council members sitting
here and we continue to come, whether
it's a police issue, a trash issue, what
are we going to do? I mean, I'm here to
challenge council. Um, we've sat here
for 8 years and I've come to council and
I've spoken I've spoken with the mayor.
We do not have a plan for the southeast
area. When is council going to go to go
to the um economic development and say
we need a plan for the southeast of
Lancaster? We talk about housing. We
talk about policing. We talk about the
trash issues. We talk about parks. And
we're doing all these comprehensive
plans, but yet we do not have a plan for
the southeast of Lancaster. And then
when we come here and we talk about
black and brown children and we say,
"Well, we don't have a plan. Our city
don't even have a plan for the area
which is mostly highly populated." I
mean, it speaks volumes. And it's time
that council at least requires that the
department of economic and community
development. You hire consultants for
every area in the city and we paid
consultants to come up with plans and
yet we have not a plan for the southeast
area. I'm asking council to respond to
that now. Not wait till the next
election to see if you sit in the seat
again, but do something now. I'm also
here talking about a stop sign. We asked
for a stop sign in 2019. I continue to
come up here and we talk about safety
and safe neighborhoods and we're told
repeatedly why we can't do anything to
prevent accidents. Well, there wasn't
enough accidents on that corner
reported. So what? There was enough near
misses and everywhere else you can look
at prevented measures, but when it comes
to addressing issues in the southeast,
we don't look at preventive measures. A
stop sign on Southoun and Green Street
is a prevented measure. We're tired of
asking. We're tired of keep coming and
coming and coming. And I agree. I vote
for people that I hope is going to
represent me. I don't want to show up at
council every meeting. If that was the
case, I would run for city council. I'm
not running because I believe I'm
electing people that's going to vote and
speak in my best interest and the
interest of the residents, especially in
the south and concerned neighborhood.
So, I'm asking you to do something about
not having a plan in the southeast area
now, not next year, not three years from
now. Start developing a plan for the
southeast. Thank you.
[Music]
Any additional comments from this
period?
Miss Desmond, I'll just remind you that
you did speak already in this period, so
I can I'll let you go very very briefly.
It is a very brief question and I
appreciate that. Thank you so much. Um,
last week I did have a question about
the water rates, um, and how we're going
to be impacted as residents, uh, the
percentage that we might anticipate of
the water rates going up as a result of
the improvement projects. Um, I found
myself so relieved that it wasn't going
to affect me potentially. So, I uh did
not receive an answer to that question.
I just sort of skipped off to my seat
and that was a disservice to the
community in Lancaster. So, I would just
like to see if there is an answer that
the community can receive and by which
date they would receive um that
anticipated increase in their rates.
Thank you. Thank you.
Uh Director Campbell, Directors
Campbell, uh follow up with you about
timeline for rate cases because those
rates are determined by those PUC rate
cases which as we spoke at last meeting
have a timeline of anywhere between 8
plus months. So, thank you. Thank you.
Any additional comments for this
period? Hearing none, we'll close public
comment this evening and we'll move to
the report of the mayor, Mayor Saraji.
Uh thank you, council president. Um
related to the use of force data, I I
want to acknowledge that uh we have made
changes to the use of force data by
adding historical data, not just the
most recent quarter. Uh I also want to
acknowledge that um that there is not
currently data related to race and
ethnicity or age but that that will be
added by the end of the week and we
should have acknowledge that in a note
on the website as we are making these
changes to um address some of the
questions that have been raised. Um I
want to also just indicate and I um I
believe that I can I can get this
information uh to you but the data that
we are reporting um uh has changed um
due to our accreditation and the ways in
which we are counting use of force has
changed uh so that after
4125 there will be additional data that
is being collected. So calls for service
with no arrest after 41 um would be
included in the use of force data.
Arrests not requiring force would be
included in the use of force data. Um
arrests requiring force were always
included in the use of force data. So
all this to say is that the data is
going to look different after um after
41 because of the accreditation uh
process. And so we will note this more
clearly on the website. It should uh
clarify the change in the collection how
the reporting data which will be uh more
and um and and include again the uh race
and ethnicity and age. So that data is
um is going to be available by the end
of the week. So I just wanted to let
council know that. The second thing is
that the department of public works
recently held a public meeting on the
city's long-term control plan of which
Mr. was in attendance. uh to reduce uh
combined sewer overflows into the
Konosoga River. As I mentioned, we are
um have four major issues that we are
trying to address presently. Um and I
have spoken about this in my state of
the city as a perfect storm of um both
unfunded mandates uh as well as the need
for improvements in our infrastructure
and as council president pointed out all
very expensive. So in addition to the
combined sewer system and the long-term
control plan, we have the lead and
copper line regulations which have
extended the responsibility of the city
and the costs uh to rate payers as well
as um our aging infrastructure
replacement needs as well as keys. When
you add all these things up, it is a lot
of money. Um I do want to want to just
focus my comments tonight on um the
combined sewer overflows and the
long-term control plan. So, the city has
made progress reducing our CSOS through
the implementation of green
infrastructure and other facility
improvements, and there's a lot more
work to be done. At the meeting, uh
Christine Vulke Hill, deputy director of
public works for utility, shared the
city's work to comply with the US EPA
consent decree, uh which was signed in
2017 and the development of our
long-term control plan to minimize the
impacts of CSOS over time. A few
takeaways for council's awareness. The
city continues to evaluate multiple
strategies to rep reduce combined sewer
overflows, including gray infrastructure
upgrades, green infrastructure,
temporary water uh storage, and the
separation of storm water from the sewer
system. The estimated cost to meet the
CSO regulations ranges from $30 million
to $73 million. The implementation
timeline will depend on the financial
impact of residents. Meaning, how
quickly we proceed depends on what our
community can afford. This is a point of
major contention because the federal
government will take into consideration
affordability only as it relates to our
combined store overflows, but not in
relation to other uh
mandates. the um the city is continuing
to assess cso reduction op options,
gathering public input and and
identifying a preferred alternative that
balances regulatory requirements with
the economic, environmental, and
community considerations unique to
Lancaster. The next step is submitting
our long-term control plan to the EPA,
initiating a process to finalize the
cost, timelines, and methods for
reducing
CSOS. While there were very few people
in attendance uh at the meeting, um this
is really important that the community
understand what is at stake. Uh there is
a recording on the city's YouTube
channel and more information can be
found at engage Lancaster and I
encourage council members uh to review
the slides because as Miss Bird
indicated that I I do believe that was a
very informative um overview of uh both
the um challenges before us, the work
that has been done, the progress that
has been made and uh what it's what the
work is now to submit the long-term
control plan uh to a new administration
which continues to evolve uh even as we
speak. Thank you. Thank you very much,
Mayor Sarrai. Next item is the report of
president council. I do have a brief
report to give this evening. Um I've
reflected a lot over the last month
about the job and duty that we entrust
our police officers with in Lancaster.
I've listened to city residents speak
about interactions with police, some
positive, some negative. I respect and
appreciate that it's a job that often
brings you into situations with people
who could be having the worst day of
their lives. I've also reflected a lot
recently about the work that our police
department has done over the last
several years to respond to the needs of
the community. Some of that response and
work we heard about earlier this evening
from organizations in our community. We
will also soon hear about the work the
department uh has done to receive
accreditation.
I do trust the internal controls and
review processes of our department and
believe that our officers are working in
good faith with our community and I
believe that continuous improvement and
responsiveness is not only possible but
necessary. I trust that our police
department will continue to uphold the
high standards our community expects and
deserves. and I look forward to
reviewing the information that was given
to us this evening about different use
of force options for youth. That
concludes my comments, council comments
this evening.
Council President, if I may, um, this is
a com more of a question. Um, when these
weather related trash concerns come up,
is there a way that the city could wave
the fees or is there a way that the
citizens can appeal the citations? Thank
you, Council Med. Yes, there is an
appeal process for citations. Um, and
it's outlined. There's a certain number
of days. I don't have it in front of me.
Um, but they uh do need to I believe
that they need to pay in the interim.
Um, but I know for sure that they need
to have the the
the reason for the citation needs to be
cleared in a certain number of days to
avoid the additional penalty for having
us have someone go out and clean it up.
Okay. and I'll I'll follow up with
council president and director Campbell
and the mayor with some additional
questions. Thank you. Additional council
comments this evening.
Council president,
thank you.
I am deeply aware of the concerns that
have arisen regarding recent reports of
police using excessive force toward
teenagers riding bikes downtown on our
downtown streets. These concerns weigh
heavily on me as I I am a mother of six
five boys, 12 grandsons and one
great-grandson. These concerns weigh
heavily on me as they should who are com
as they should all of who are committed
to ensuring the safety of every
individual within our city particularly
particularly our young people. First and
foremost, I want to acknowledge the
voices of those who have spoken out.
Your concerns are valid and are a vital
part of keeping our city government
transparent and fair. As a member of
city council, my responsibility is to
listen to you, understand your concerns,
and work tirelessly to address them.
This moment calls for for us to reflect
on the kind of community we want to
build. One where young people can
navigate through our neighborhoods
without fear. Where families can feel
assured of their children's safety and
where law enforcement earns the trust of
those who are sworn to protect they are
sworn to protect. In doing so, I must
recognize that public safety is a
partnership between residents and
police. Mutual respect and understanding
are essential in fostering a community
where everyone feels safe and
valid. We must ensure our lo we must
ensure that our local law enforcement
embodies the values of fairness and
respect especially when interacting with
our youth. To that end, I reviewed the
video footage and reports and I review
and I also reviewed the bicycle safety
ordinance number 158 of
2023. In addition, I also listened to
community members thoughts and feelings
regarding this incident to uncover what
happened and why. After this thorough
review, I have concluded that the youth
were in violation of bike riding safety
protocol. and when stopped did not
cooperate with the police. Therefore,
the police acted within law enforcement
practices and training protocols in
stopping and detaining youth. As we move
forward, this moment calls for us to
reflect on the kind of community we want
to build. One where young people can
navigate their neighborhoods without
fear. Where families can feel assured of
their children's safety
and where law enforcement earns the
trust of those they are sworn to
protect. As a member of city council,
I'm committed to the safety of our young
people and mutual respect and
understanding of to foster a community
where everyone feels safe and valued.
Let us work together as partners and
continue to build a city defined by
fairness and mutual
respect. Thank you for your engagement,
your vigilance, and your commitment to
our community
well-being. That's pretty much what I
have to say. You know, I'm concerned
about um all the things that have
happened over the last few weeks that
have um centered
around the incident that happened
downtown. Um that could have been that
could have been very well one of my
children, one of my
grandchildren. And you know,
I you know, all we have to do is try I
have to try and do better. You know, it
has to we have to meet at some happy
medium. And I really think that most of
the things that have happened here, some
of it has been very brutal. And and you
know, the name
calling, I think that's unnecessary.
We're not going to get anything solved
with calling each other names or
thinking bad thoughts about each other.
We're going to have to sit down at the
table, discuss what needs to happen, and
stop making so many demands on each
other that are going to make people
angry.
Thank you. Thank you, Council Pri. Any
additional council comments this
evening? Hearing none and having reached
the end of our agenda, I'll hear a
motion to adjurnn. Motion to adjurnn.
Second. A motion and a second. All in
favor? I. Wejour. Thank you.